>>> TONIGHT, A CYNICAL POWER
PLAY.
THAT'S HOW REPUBLICAN SENATOR
TED CRUZ DESCRIBES THE PUSH FOR
THE JOHN LEWIS VOTING RIGHTS
ADVANCEMENT ACT.
AS DEMOCRATS MAKE A RENEWED PUSH
FOR THE VOTING RIGHTS WITH THE
BILL WHICH WOULD MAKE IT EASIER
FOR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
MINORITIES TO CHALLENGE ELECTION
RULES THAT THEY BELIEVE ARE
DISCRIMINATORY.
>> STATE LEGISLATORS AND OTHERS
ARE GOING TO DEFAME AND DIMINISH
OUR DEMOCRACY, WE IN THE
CONGRESS HAVE A DUTY TO DEFEND
IT.
>> THIS BILL IS A DISASTER.
WHY CHANGE WHAT HAS WORKED FOR
240 YEARS?
>> WE KNOW THAT JOHN LEWIS
BILL -- LET ME JUST STEP BACK --
WILL STOP STATES WITH A HISTORY
OF RACIAL DISCRIMINATION FROM
ROLLING BACK VOTING RIGHTS IN
THE FUTURE.
>> THIS BILL IS AN ASSAULT ON
DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS A POWER GRAB.
IT'S CYNICAL.
AND IT'S WRONG.
>> OUTFRONT NOW, STACEY ABRAMS,
FORMER DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR IN GEORGIA AND THE
FOUNDER OF FAIR FIGHT ACTION,
WHICH FIGHTS VOTER SUPPRESSION.
SO, YOU HEARD SENATOR GRASSLEY
SAY THIS BILL IS A DISASTER.
SENATOR CRUZ CALLING IT A
ASSAULT ON DEMOCRACY, A POWER
GRAB BY DEMOCRATS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM?
>> WELL, I WOULD, FIRST, POINT
OUT THAT SENATOR GRASSLEY
REFERENCED 240-YEAR HISTORY
WHERE IT HAS TAKEN MULTIPLE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS,
MULTIPLE FEDERAL LAWS, AND
UNTOLD NUMBER OF COURT CASES TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO DEMOCRACY.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, IN THE WAKE
OF THE 2020 ELECTION, WE HAVE
WATCHED 48 STATES TRY TO PASS
LAWS.
WE'VE HAD 19 SUCCESSFULLY DO SO
TO ROLL BACK ACCESS TO THE RIGHT
TO VOTE AND SO IT'S BEEN 240
YEARS OF FIGHTING TO SIMPLY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE RIGHT TO VOTE FOR
SO MANY AMERICANS WHO SHOULD BE
ENTITLED TO IT VIA THEIR
CITIZENSHIP.
AS FOR SENATOR CRUZ, THE ONLY
CYNICISM IS TO STAND IN A STATE
LIKE TEXAS WHICH HAS TAKEN UPON
ITSELF TO OUTDO ALMOST EVERY
OTHER STATE WITH ATTACK AND
ASSAULT ON DEMOCRACY AND ACCESS
TO COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
TO SUGGEST DEFENDING THE FREEDOM
TO VOTE, THAT THOSE ARE CYNICAL
ACTS, UNFORTUNATELY, IS A
PARTISAN RESPONSE AND NOT A
PATRIOTIC RESPONSE.
PATRIOTISM SAYS WE DEFEND THE
RIGHT TO VOTE NO MATTER WHO
NEEDS TO USE IT AND THAT'S THE
WORK WE ARE DOING AND THAT'S THE
WORK OF THE JOHN LEWIS VOTING
RIGHTS ACT AND THE FREEDOM TO
VOTE ACT.
>> LET ME ASK BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE WATCHING WHO I MAY
SAY, OKAY, DEMOCRATS TRIED
REALLY HARD AND CONGRESS FAILED
TO GET THIS DONE SO THAT JUST
WAS ANOTHER THING THEY FAILED TO
DO.
BUT THIS IS THE FOURTH SENATE
HEARING ON THIS -- THIS SESSION
OF CONGRESS ON VOTING RIGHTS AND
AS I SAID, THEY -- THEY FAILED
BEFORE TO PUSH THROUGH THE MORE
SWEEPING FOR THE PEOPLE ACT.
THERE HAVE BEEN NO SIGNS SINCE
THAT FAILURE THAT TEN REPUBLICAN
SENATORS ARE GOING TO BACK THIS
BILL, RIGHT?
BECAUSE YOU NEED -- YOU NEED
THAT FILIBUSTER-PROOF MAJORITY
IN ORDER TO GET IT THROUGH.
WHY DO YOU THINK THIS TIME WILL
BE DIFFERENT AND THIS WILL
SUCCEED?
>> I WOULD REJECT THE NOTION
THAT WE'VE SEEN FAILURE.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS MOVEMENT.
EACH TIME, THERE HAS BEEN THE
ARGUMENT THAT THERE IS NO WAY TO
MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD, WE HAVE
SEEN SENATORS COME TO THE TABLE
AND TAKE ACTION.
WE HAVE SEEN SENATOR JOE MANCHIN
PUT FORWARD A FRAMEWORK.
AND WHEN WE WERE ABLE TO WORK
COLLECTIVELY TO MEET THOSE
CONCERNS, WE SAW HIS NAME GO ON
THAT BILL, AND WE SAW -- THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE STAND UP
AND SAY, TOGETHER, THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO PROTECT THE FREEDOM
TO VOTE.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO NOW IS TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH THIS FORWARD.
I WATCHED YOUR EARLIER SEGMENT
ON THE DEBT CEILING AND THE
REALITY IS WE ARE IN A BIT OF A
GROUNDHOG'S DAY WITH THE
CONVERSATION OF DEMOCRACY.
WE KEEP HAVING TO HAVE THESE
FIGHTS.
BUT LUCKILY FOR ME, LUCKILY FOR
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS, WHEN WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT, WE WIN.
AND IN THIS FIGHT, THIS FIGHT
FOR FAIR ELECTIONS, THIS FIGHT
FOR FREEDOM TO VOTE, WE BELIEVE
THAT IF WE KEEP PUSHING AND IF
WE INVOKE THE SPIRIT OF THOSE
WHO'VE PUSHED THIS SO HARD, WE
WILL GET TO THE PROMISE LAND AND
WE WILL GET TO THE FINISH LINE
AND FINALLY HAVE A MINIMUM SET
OF STANDARDS FOR THE RIGHT TO
VOTE IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE WILL HAVE THE JOHN LEWIS
VOTING RIGHTS ADVANCEMENT ABOUT
THAT RESTORES A PINNACLE OF
ACHIEVEMENT FOR OUR DEMOCRACY,
AND THAT IS ENSURING THAT THE
MOST VULNERABLE AMONG US HAVE
ACCESS TO THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
>> SO AS YOU SPEAK OUT, THERE
ARE MANY WHO LISTEN.
SOME WHO SUPPORT YOU AND SOME
WHO DO NOT.
SO ONE OF THOSE -- AT LEAST ONE
OF THOSE USED TO BE
FORMER-PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BUT HE RECENTLY INVOKED YOUR
NAME MULTIPLE TIMES AT A RALLY
IN YOUR STATE OF GEORGIA AND HE
SLAMMED YOUR REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR, BRIAN KEMP, FOR
REFUSING TO BACK TRUMP'S BIG LIE
AND OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> WHEN STACEY ABRAMS SAYS I'M
NOT GOING TO CONCEDE, THAT'S
OKAY.
NO PROBLEM.
OH, SHE'S NOT GOING TO CONCEDE.
SHE'S NOT GOING TO CONCEDE.
OF COURSE, HAVING HER, I THINK,
MIGHT BE BETTER THAN HAVING YOUR
EXISTING GOVERNOR IF YOU WANT TO
KNOW THE TRUTH.
STACEY, WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
HIS PLACE?
IT'S OKAY WITH ME.
>> UH, OKAY, SO, OF COURSE, YOU
RAN AGAINST GOVERNOR KEMP.
BUT NOW, YOU HAVE GOT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OUT THERE SAYING THESE
THINGS ABOUT YOU.
DOES HIM INVOKING YOUR NAME LIKE
THIS HELP OR HURT YOU?
>> IT'S IRRELEVANT.
HIS POSTURE IS NOT RELEVANT TO
THE WORK THAT I'M DOING OR TO
THE POSITIONS I TAKE.
MY RESPONSIBILITY IS TO DO WHAT
I CAN TO ENSURE THAT NO MATTER
WHO YOU ARE, AND NO MATTER WHO
YOU CHOOSE, THAT YOU HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO VOTE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND THAT IS WHY WE HAVE TO KEEP
LASER FOCUSED ON THE ASSAULT ON
OUR DEMOCRACY.
AN ASSAULT THAT NOT ONLY
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th BUT HAS
HAPPENED AGAIN AND AGAIN SINCE
THAT TIME IN STATEHOUSES THAT
HAVE RESTRICTED ACCESS TO THE
RIGHT TO VOTE AND CONSTRICTED
NOT ONLY THAT BUT THE ABILITY OF
ELECTION WORKERS TO DO THEIR
JOBS.
WE ARE SEEING ELECTION WORKERS
BEING PUT UNDER DIRECT ASSAULT
AND THAT IS SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
PUSH BACK AGAINST.
WE HAVE TO STOP THIS AVERSION OF
OUR ELECTIONS.
AND BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
GENERATIONAL MOMENT OF
REDISTRICTING, WE HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY SINGLE VOTER HAS THE
RIGHT TO PICK THEIR LEADERS, NOT
HAVE THEIR -- NOT BE PICKED BY
THEIR POLITICIANS BASED ON WHO
THEY THINK THEY'LL VOTE FOR.
>> SO, YOU KNOW, BUT ON THIS
FRONT, YOU KNOW, AND OBVIOUSLY,
YOU POINTED OUT THE VIOLENCE
ABOUT -- AGAINST ELECTION
WORKERS.
YOU HAVE SEEN THAT IN YOUR OWN
STATE, RIGHT, AGAINST ELECTION
WORKERS AT EVERY LEVEL
REGARDLESS OF THEIR POLITICS AND
REGARDLESS OF WHO THEY VOTED FOR
IN THE LAST ELECTION.
THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH
SPECULATION ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO NOW THAT YOU MAY RUN
AGAIN AGAINST GOVERNOR KEMP THIS
YEAR.
YOU HAVEN'T RULED IT OUT.
WHERE DO YOU STAND TONIGHT?
>> I STAND ON THE SIDE OF
PASSAGE OF THE FREEDOM TO VOTE
ACT AND THE PASSAGE OF THE JOHN
LEWIS VOTING RIGHTS ADVANCEMENT
ACT.
AND I'M -- I'M VERY INTENTIONAL
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
STOP TREATING THIS AS ONE MORE
POLITICAL BATTLE.
THIS IS A BATTLE FOR THE SOUL OF
AMERICA.
THIS IS A QUESTION OF WHETHER WE
WILL BE A DEMOCRACY THAT CAN BE
LOOKED TO BY OTHER NATIONS AS A
SYMBOL OF WHAT WE CAN BE.
OR IF WE ARE GOING TO BE SEEN ON
THE DOWNWARD SIDE OF
AUTHORITARIANISM.
>> DO YOU THINK YOU CAN GET --
YOU CAN GET TEN REPUBLICANS
ONBOARD?
I KNOW YOU ARE TRYING TO -- TO
PRESENT IT AS YOU'VE SEEN
PROGRESS AND I HEAR WHY YOU ARE
DOING THAT BECAUSE YOU ARE ABLE
TO HAVE IT COME BACK.
I GET -- I GET HOW YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT IT.
BUT YET, YOU HAVE TO GET TEN OF
THEM.
AND RIGHT NOW, THERE'S NOT EVEN
ONE.
>> I SPENT 11 YEARS IN THE
GEORGIA STATEHOUSE.
11 YEARS IN THE MINORITY AND
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THERE ARE
STRANGE BEDFELLOWS EVERY DAY ON
LEGISLATION.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, WHEN YOU
ARE FIGHTING FOR FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS, WHEN YOU ARE FIGHTING
FOR THE FREEDOM TO PROTECT OUR
DEMOCRACY AND TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT DEMOCRACY, WE DON'T HAVE
THE LUXURY OF CYNICISM.
WE DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY OF
GIVING UP.
I DO NOT KNOW.
I CANNOT SAY TODAY EXACTLY HOW
THIS WILL COME TOGETHER BUT I
WILL TELL YOU THAT I WILL SPEND
EVERY SINGLE DAY FROM NOW UNTIL
IT DOES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING OUR -- OUR FREEDOMS